so the idea with Mark one both Mark I
and Mark I is the new Glen
can uh carry it from the surface of
Earth to the surface
of the Moon exactly so the Mark 1 is
Expendable the lunar the lunar lander
we're developing for NASA the mark 2
Lander that's part of uh the Artemus
program they call it the sustaining
Lander program so that Lander is
designed to be
reusable it can land on the surface of
the Moon in a in a single stage
configuration and then take off so the
whole the you know the if you look at
the Apollo
program the lunar lander and Apollo was
really two stages it would land on the
surface and then it would leave The
Descent stage on the surface of the Moon
and only the assent stage would go back
up into lunar orbit where it would
Rendevous with the Command Module here
what we're doing is we have a single
stage lunar lander that carries down
enough propellant so it can bring the
whole thing back up so that it can be
reused over and over and the point of
doing that of course is to reduce cost
so that you can make Lunar missions more
affordable over time which is that's one
of NASA's big objectives because this
time the the whole point of Artemis is
go back to the moon but this time to
stay so you know back in the Apollo
program we went to the moon six times
and then ended the program and it really
was too expensive to to continue and so
there's a few questions there but one is
how do you stay on the moon what what
ideas do you have
about uh yeah like a sustain sustaining
life where a few folks can stay there
for prol long periods of time well um
one of the things we're working on is um
using lunar resources like lunar
regolith to
manufacture Commodities and even solar
cells on the surface of the Moon we've
already built a solar cell that is
completely made from lunar reguli
simulant and this solar cell is only
about 7% uh power efficient so it's very
inefficient compared to you know the
more advanced solar cells that we make
here on Earth but if you can figure out
how to make a practical solar cell
Factory that you can land on the surface
of the Moon and then the raw material
for those solar cells is simply lunar
regolith then you can just uh you know
continue to churn out solar cells on the
surface of the Moon have lots of power
on the surface of the Moon that will
make it easier for people to live on the
moon uh similarly we're working on
extracting oxygen from lunar regolith so
lunar regolith by weight is has a lot of
oxygen in it it's bound very tightly you
know in as oxides with other elements
and so it you have to separate the
oxygen which is very energy intensive so
that also could work together with the
uh solar cells but if you can uh and
then
ultimately we may be able to find
practical
quantities of Ice uh in the permanently
shadowed craters on the poles of the
Moon and we know there is ice water um
in those uh or water ice in those
craters and we know that we can break
that down uh with electrolisis into
hydrogen and oxygen and then you'd not
only have oxygen but you'd also have a
very good high efficiency propellant uh
fuel in in hydrogen so there's a lot the
there's a lot we can do to make the moon
more sustainable over time but the very
first step the thing the kind of gate
that all of that has to go through is we
need to be able to
land uh cargo and humans on the surface
of the Moon at an acceptable
cost